Anastasiya Tarnouskaya:
All right.
Good morning, everybody.
Thanks for starting day two
at Build with us at BRK 260.
Today we'll be talking about how
you can build local, AI-powered
apps for the over 1 billion
Windows devices out there,
no need for a cloud
setup, no token costs,
and no network needed,
all through a stack that's
generally available and ready
for your production workloads,
and powered with the latest
innovation from across Microsoft
and our silicon partners: AMD,
Intel, Nvidia, and Qualcomm.
We also have several
announcements and a ton
of live demos lined up across
five devices, so it's going
to be quite something.
So let's go ahead
and get started.
We are your speakers
for this session.
My name is Anastasia, and I'm a
Product Manager at Microsoft,
working on Windows ML.
Aditi Narvekar: And
my name is Aditi.
I'm a Product Manager
at Microsoft,
working on the AI APIs.
Anastasiya Tarnouskaya: Awesome.
So for those of you that
attended the keynote yesterday,
you'll have heard Satya talk
about unmetered intelligence,
or shifting from always running
your AI workloads in the cloud
to running them locally
using just the hardware
on everyday PCs, and
only going to the cloud
when your workload truly needs
it, and it's worth the cost.
And thanks to recent
advancements in AI models,
hardware, and the software
stacks that run them, today,
every Windows PC is becoming
increasingly AI-capable,
leveraging powerful GPUs
for maximum performance
and compute-intensive
workloads, NPUs on Copilot+ PCs
for maximum power efficiency
and always-on experiences,
and even CPUs for maximum reach,
especially with
lighter-weight workloads.
But enough talking about it.
Let's take a look at some
of the real-world examples
of what developers are
building using local AI
through Foundry on Windows.
[ Music ]
Aditi Narvekar: Wow.
So you are telling me all those
experiences are running AI
models locally?
Anastasiya Tarnouskaya:
That's right,
all local, no cloud setup.
All right.
So let's talk about
why developers
and enterprises are
betting on local AI,
from Adobe to WhatsApp,
building some incredible local
AI-powered experiences.
The first is, running models
locally can help improve privacy
and security, because
there is no customer
or sensitive enterprise data
that ever has to
leave the device.
Second, it reduces latency
because there's no round-trip
that's needed to the cloud,
and that's going to be
particularly critical
for real-time workloads.
Third, it enables AI
experiences without the need
for a network connection,
because all of the compute
is taking place right
on the device.
And finally, not all AI
workloads need cloud scale,
and running models locally can
significantly cut down costs.
And it's not just developers
that are betting on local AI.
Microsoft experiences are
betting on it as well,
from Outlook Summarize
to GitHub Copilot,
all built using the same
stack that's being offered
to developers and enterprises.
Aditi Narvekar: So how can
developers get started building
these AI-powered apps?
Anastasiya Tarnouskaya:
Yeah, I'm glad you asked.
That's what Foundry
on Windows is for.
And that includes
the Windows AI APIs,
which are the turnkey APIs,
powered by Windows inbox models
that you can use for common
tasks, such as natural language,
vision, and many others.
And these are generally
going to be the easiest way
for developers to get started
building local, AI-powered
experiences on Windows.
Then for developers
that are interested
in using common,
open-source models,
they can run those locally using
Foundry Local, which has a range
of models that have already been
pre-optimized to run really well
across all Windows devices.
And then you can use Windows ML
to run your own custom model.
This can be one that you
trained yourself or found
on Hugging Face and then
fine-tuned for your scenario.
And Windows ML is also
the underlying backbone
that powers the entire
Foundry on Windows stack,
enabling its core
cross-silicon capabilities.
All right.
Now it's time to introduce
our demo scenario,
the Unmetered Token Café,
which is powered by Foundry
on Windows, where
the coffee is great,
and cloud token costs
are a thing of the past.
So this café just opened.
Like any small business, the
owners are wearing every hat,
doing everything from
taking customer orders
to running their
Experimental Brews program.
They don't have the budget
for cloud AI bills.
They don't want to have to rely
on their flaky café network
for all of their business
operations, and they need all
of their workloads to
just work using the PCs
that they already own.
All right.
So throughout the
rest of the session,
we're going to be enabling
various local AI-powered
experiences for this café
through Foundry on Windows.
But as you can imagine,
the possibilities are
really limitless in terms
of how you can use Foundry
on Windows and local AI
for your own apps and
enterprise workflows.
So to get started, Aditi,
what would be the best way
for the café to enable
customer orders?
Aditi Narvekar: Great question.
Well, the café has
a drive-through,
and customers drive up.
They speak their order
into the microphone.
And we need to convert their
spoken order into text.
And the easiest way to
get started with this is
through the Windows AI APIs.
So today I'm going to demo
to you my sample
drive-through application.
I'm going to be running this
on my Microsoft Surface device
with a Qualcomm Snapdragon NPU.
All righty.
So here is my
drive-through application.
And let's say a
customer rolls up.
They're going to hit that
"Press to Talk" button,
speak into the microphone,
and say their order.
In the back end, this is going
to use our brand-new
speech recognition API
to convert their spoken order
into a string into text.
So Anastasiya, tell me, what
would you like to order today?
Anastasiya Tarnouskaya:
Yeah, I think I would
like to get a matcha latte.
I would want to get it
with soy milk, extra hot,
because I'm always cold,
and then maybe a
croissant on the side as well.
Aditi Narvekar: And there we go.
Here is Anastasiya's
order outputted
by our new speech
recognition API.
So this particular API took
input from the microphone,
but it can also take input from
audio files and audio streams,
like if you were trying
to enable a call
or meeting type of scenario.
So that demo, though, that
was running on the NPU,
right? But what about
the devices at the café
that might not be Copilot+ PCs?
Would they still be able
to run the workload?
Yeah, the really great thing
about this API is it runs
best on Copilot+ PCs,
it uses the NPU,
but it also works for CPU.
Now when we first released
the AI APIs, we released them
for the NPU, but we heard
so much customer feedback
that you would all like
to address a much broader
hardware spectrum.
And we hear you.
So today, we're super
excited to share
that we're expanding the support
of many of the AI APIs to run
on CPUs and to run on GPUs.
So you can reach a broader
set of devices, a broader set
of customers with these APIs.
So for my next demo, I'm
going to show you Phi Silica,
our small language model,
newly running on GPU.
Okay. So all of those
orders that we took
in through the speech to text
API, well, they're sitting
as unstructured text
in a barista queue.
And we want someone
looking at this queue
to really easily be able to
understand what they need to do.
So here I have my
ordering application,
and a barista is going
to take a look at this
and maybe hit one
of these orders.
In the back end, this is going
to use Phi Silica,
running on GPU.
It's going to extract all
the relevant information
and structure its output
as JSON, which, again,
is using a new API for
structuring Phi Silica output.
You can see on the task manager
there's a little spike on GPU,
because it's all running
locally on the GPU.
And here is the JSON
output that I wanted
from the language model.
And you could see, this is
the drink I want, the size,
the modifiers,
quantities, everything.
Really quick glance, you
know what you're making.
And how I implemented this?
Actually pretty straightforward
to use the AI APIs.
It's just a few lines of code.
All of our APIs use a very
similar calling pattern.
So first, I'm going to check if
the model is ready on the device
by calling this "get
ready state" function.
If it's not ready, I
call "ensure ready async",
which is going to install it.
Then next step is initialize
the model with "create async".
And then the very last step
is generating a response
from the model.
Here I've done a little
bit of fancier work
with defining the JSON
schema that I want.
But I just call this "generate
structured JSON response".
And there you have it.
Really easy to use
the Windows AI APIs.
[ Applause ]
We already have
production experiences
that are using Phi
Silica on GPU.
For example, if you've
used the summarize feature
in Outlook, that
uses Phi on GPU.
Now let's take a broader
look at the set of AI APIs
that are available today.
Starting on the top left, we
have our task-specific APIs.
Many of these are already
generally available.
These are things like
image description,
conversation summary, text
summary, text to table.
But we know that real
scenarios sometimes need more
customization, and that's where
our customization APIs come in.
This is fine-tuning the language
model with LoRA adapters,
doing app content
search, or RAG,
and structuring your
language model output.
On the top right, we
have our media APIs.
This is video super resolution
and speech recognition.
So that enables audio
video features for you.
And then on the bottom
corner, we have imaging APIs.
This is a growing
set of imaging APIs.
And you can take these,
apply them to any domain,
accessibility, productivity,
enterprise workflows,
you name it.
And just to give you a
glimpse, these are the APIs
that we have now expanded
to run on GPUs and CPUs.
All right.
So we already have a ton of ISVs
that are using the AI APIs.
But today we're really excited
to have Alfred from ClipChamp
with us to show us
video super resolution.
And he's going to
be demoing this
on an Asus device
with the AMD NPU.
Alfred: Thanks, Aditi.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Alfred from
Microsoft ClipChamp,
the free video editor
built into Windows.
In ClipChamp, we want video
creation to be simple
and accessible for everyone.
A common part of
editing is using clips
from different sources
like phones, old videos,
and screen recordings, but those
clips may not match the final
export resolution, making parts
of the video look
soft or blurry.
This is where video super
resolution, or VSR, can help.
It uses AI to upscale a
video and add details
that simple resizing cannot.
We are adding this local
model into ClipChamp,
so users can do this
without leaving the editor.
The flow is simple.
Select a video, open
the "Upscale" panel,
choose a resolution,
then click "Upscale."
When it's running, let
me switch to the code
and show how we integrate VSR.
We start by making sure
that the model is ready.
Then we create a video
scaler instance.
With the scaler ready, here
is how we upscale each frame.
This method receives a decoder
frame from the pipeline,
along with an output surface.
We pass both to scale and
out comes the upscale frame.
Finally, the encoder
can turn them back
into a video, as simple as that.
The upscale should be done.
And yep. Oh, wait, it's still
-- oh, yeah, there we go.
It's run. Here's a
quick comparison video.
Watch the face.
It looks much sharper
on the right.
It's pretty cool, right?
[ Applause ]
And here's the best part.
VSR can run on both CPU and NPU.
So more Windows
devices can use it.
And NPU makes the
experience even better.
Anyone can get sharper
videos inside ClipChamp
and in your apps, too.
Now's your turn.
We can't wait to see what
you can do with VSR.
Thank you very much.
Enjoy the rest of
Microsoft Build.
[ Applause ]
Aditi Narvekar: Thank you,
Alfred, for that demo.
I know that at the café,
they're definitely going
to be using VSR, ClipChamp, to
make their marketing videos
to help promote the cafe.
Okay. So in the keynote,
you might have heard
Satya talking about Aion.
And you're wondering, how
does Aion fit into our story?
Well, Aion is going to be
the successor to Phi Silica.
And it will be available
via the AI APIs.
But until then, you can go
to that link and try it
out for yourself, and we
can give you a little sneak
preview today.
Okay. So if you remember
Build last year,
we showed the Prompt API
in the Edge browser.
Today this is being
powered by Aion.
And you can also try Prompt API.
Just toggle on a few
flags in the Edge Canary.
And so here I have a prompt.
I have a system prompt.
And I'm going to hit "Run,"
and this will generate a
response right here on the side.
There we go.
Okay. So today, with Aion,
we are getting even bigger
improvements in model quality,
in context window, faster
tokens per second.
And this is going to level up
the language model experience
that you get with the AI APIs.
And just like all of our other
APIs, Aion is going to be in box.
So you don't need to
handle any distribution.
Windows is going to
do it all for you.
Okay. So now you have
seen in-box APIs.
But what if you want to run
common open-source models?
Well, that is what
Foundry Local is for.
You might be familiar with
Microsoft Foundry on Azure.
Well, we have Foundry
Local, which enables you
to run common, open-source
models on CPUs, GPUs, and NPUs.
And now Foundry Local is in GA.
So Anastasiya, tell me, what is
the next thing we should enable
for the coffee shop?
Anastasiya Tarnouskaya: Yeah.
Well, there are lots of
customers like me that really
like their matcha lattes.
I want to make sure that
the cafe never runs out.
How should they
implement, maybe,
an inventory management system?
Aditi Narvekar: Yeah, they
are getting a ton of demos --
excuse me, they're getting
a ton of deliveries,
and they need to
easily take inventory
of everything that's
being dropped off.
Delivery drivers are dropping
stuff off daily, weekly.
So we are going to
use Foundry Local
to power an inventory
application.
Okay. So I'm going
to get started
and kick off my inventory app.
And here, I will
upload an image of all
of my dropped off product.
And once that model is
loaded into memory,
I'll hit "Identify Items."
In the back end, this is going
to use the Qwen 3.5
vision language model.
It's brand new to the
Foundry Local catalog.
And it's going to classify
everything, describe everything
in that image, so it makes
it really easy for me
to know what I got and
log the inventory.
There we go.
So I can show you in code
how straightforward it is
to use Foundry Local.
In my experience, the best way
to get started is go check
out the GitHub repo.
There's a ton of samples there.
Really easy jumping off point.
So first, I call this
"get model" function.
To that, I'm passing Qwen 3.5,
the 9 billion parameter
variant that I want.
Then Step 2, I call
"model.download"
to download it to the device.
Then I'm going to call
"model.load," load
it into memory.
Once it is loaded into memory,
I will call "create
responses client."
And then the last step is
actually generating a response.
So here I call "create
streaming," and I pass
to it an input, which is my
input image, and a prompt,
"You are a helpful coffee
shop inventory assistant."
And here we go.
There's a description
of everything
that came in that image.
Anastasiya Tarnouskaya:
Phew, what a relief
that I'm always going to be able
to get my matcha
latte at this cafe.
And really cool that Foundry
Local will take care of things
like model management as well.
Aditi, could you tell us a
little bit more about how
that all works and the
tech behind Foundry Local?
Aditi Narvekar: Yeah,
great question.
Well, starting on the
left, you have access
to a rich model catalog.
This is everything from
open-source GPT models
to DeepSeek, Mistral, Qwen, Phi,
even Whisper for
speech scenarios.
And today, what is net new?
Well, we have new
variants of Qwen,
like that vision
language model you saw,
and there's new
speech models, too.
And you can access all of these
through the Foundry Local SDK,
which abstracts away all the
complexity of model management
and device-specific
hardware acceleration,
whether that is for
CPU, GPU, or NPU.
You don't need to write
device-specific code.
And then on the right is
the Foundry Local CLI.
So you can play
around with models,
see which best fits
your scenario.
All right.
With that, I'm going to
hand it to Anastasiya.
Tell us about Windows ML.
Anastasiya Tarnouskaya:
Yeah, thanks, Aditi.
Now those earlier
scenarios, as you saw,
were using ready-to-use
AI models and APIs.
But if you wanted to run your
own custom model, for example,
one that you trained yourself
or maybe found on Hugging Face,
that's where you would
use Windows ML directly.
Aditi Narvekar: So what kind
of devices can the coffee
shop use to use Windows ML?
Anastasiya Tarnouskaya:
Yeah, well,
the good news is Windows ML
has really broad support,
starting with Windows 10 1809
and above, Windows Server
2019 and above, and
even Windows 365,
to provide a cloud-based Windows
environment so that developers
or potentially employees
at the Unmetered Token Café
can access their Windows ML
development environment
from any device.
That can be another PC, a Mac,
mobile device, or a browser.
All right.
So one scenario where Windows ML
is going to be really helpful
at the Unmetered Token Café is
for their Experimental Brews
program, where the cafe rolls
out new menu items to customers
and then classify sentiment
for the reviews that
come in to get a sense
of how the menu item is doing.
For this scenario, I'm going
to be using a custom,
open-source model.
So Windows ML is going
to be the perfect fit,
allowing me to run the model
locally and performantly
through one unified
stack that scales
across all Windows devices.
Now for those of you that have
spent some time in this space,
you'll know that it's not
actually always as simple
as just taking a
model and running it.
Sometimes you'll need to spend
some time optimizing your model.
And depending on your scenario
and your target hardware,
that can be somewhat
complex and time consuming.
For example, if your model
doesn't export cleanly,
or if some of your model
operators aren't supported
out of the box on
your target hardware.
And so to help with just
that, we're really excited
to announce the brand-new
Windows ML CLI,
which is now
available in preview
for you to try it on GitHub.
And it's intended
to cater to all
of your model
optimization needs.
So check it out at
aka.ms/winmlcli.
All right.
So let's talk about what the
Windows ML CLI provides.
First off, it provides a
one-stop tool chain and set
of agent skills, so
that as a developer,
you can take your model through
conversion, optimization,
and benchmarking
through one flow.
Next, the CLI is built to give
developers maximum flexibility.
You can use primitive
commands to run each stage
of the optimization
pipeline yourself
and have really hands-on
control over exactly how
that takes place, or you
can keep things simple
and run the whole thing end to
end using a prebuilt config.
And third, the CLI is built to
integrate with AI workflows
and agents and provides
a set of agent skills
to make it really easy
for you to get started
and incorporate it into
your AI-driven workflows,
for example, using
GitHub Copilot
or your tooling of choice.
And then for developers
that prefer to get started
with some UI, you can also check
out the Foundry
Toolkit extension
in VS Code to get started.
All right.
So let's see this in action.
We are going to be running
the Windows ML CLI
to optimize the model that
we are going to be using
to classify sentiment for
new items at the café.
And I'm going to be running
this demo on a Surface Laptop
for Business, Seventh Edition
laptop with Intel processors.
But it's important to
note that the output
of the CLI is actually going
to be a portable model
that I'm going to be able
to run across all devices.
So let's check it out.
All right.
So here, I have a Python
virtual environment
with the CLI already running.
So let me go ahead and
type in the WinML command.
And what this is going to do is
list out all of the commands
that are available for me
to try out through the CLI.
Let me then go ahead and
type in "WinML Catalog".
And this is going to list
out just some of the models
that are available
for me to optimize
through the Windows ML CLI.
But as you can imagine, you can
use it for many more models,
for example, other models that
you might find on Hugging Face
or your own model that
you trained yourself
and then converted
to ONNX format.
So Aditi, out of this
list, is there any model
that catches your eye that
we can potentially use
for this sentiment
analysis scenario?
Aditi Narvekar: Yeah.
Is there one there called
"Cardiff NLP for Sentiment"?
Anastasiya Tarnouskaya: Yeah.
Great eye.
Okay. So the next thing that
we would do is run the WinML
"Inspect" command.
Now just for time, I've
already pre-run this command,
and I'm going to show you
what the output is going
to look like.
And what this command
does is it helps me rule
out common reasons why a
particular model might not be a
good fit to optimize through the
WinML CLI before I spend too
much time on it.
In this case, I
already ran this.
The output is looking good.
I don't see any errors.
So I'm good to continue forward.
The next thing that I would
do is actually go ahead
and export my model.
This command I've also
pre-run, just for time,
and I'm showing you here
what the output looks like.
And what this is going to do is
essentially just convert the
model to ONNX format.
And then that's what we are
going to use for the rest
of the optimization workflow.
Now that we have exported
our model, let's go ahead
and run the "Analyze" command.
And what this is
going to do is read
through my model graph
operator by operator and see
which of my model operators are
supported on my target hardware.
In this case, if I scroll
up and take a look
at what the output looks
like for Qualcomm,
I can see that a bunch
of the operators here
are showing in green.
That's good.
That means the operator
is fully supported.
For anything that's
showing in yellow,
that means it's
partially supported,
so it might fall back to CPU.
And if I were to see anything in
red, which I don't have here,
that would mean that the
operator isn't supported at all.
So now that I've run
this, the next thing
that I would do is run
the "Optimize" command.
And let me just resize
this really quickly
so that you can see
me running that.
So I'm running the
"Optimize" command.
And this is going to
take in the config file
that the previous step generated
to actually rewrite my model
graph, fuse graph operators,
and address any of
those operators
that weren't fully supported.
So I just ran that, and
that ran really quickly.
So now let me rerun
the "Analyze" command,
because I want to make sure
that everything is showing
up as green before
I take next steps.
All right.
And as you can see,
that's running.
And now everything across
the board is showing
up as green, which is great.
So the last thing that
I'm going to do here
in the CLI is run
this "Perf" command.
And this is going to help
me benchmark my model.
It's going to give me some
stats about throughput
and other indicators for
me to have confidence
that the model is ready for
my production workload.
And here, you can see we're
getting a live graph showing
NPU utilization.
It's really high,
so that's great.
And my performance is
looking pretty good as well.
So I think I'm good to go ahead
and move forward
with this model.
Aditi Narvekar: Yeah,
it was also super cool
that everything you needed was
available in one CLI tool.
Anastasiya Tarnouskaya:
That's right.
And in this particular workflow,
I ran each command,
command by command.
But I could have also
used a prebuilt config
to run the whole
thing end to end.
Or I could have
used GitHub Copilot
and had my agents do the model
optimization flow for me.
All right.
So now that we've
optimized our model,
let's talk about how Windows ML
is going to help us run it and,
more broadly, how Windows
ML can benefit you
in running your own
custom AI workloads
across Windows GPUs,
NPUs, and CPUs.
First off, scale.
Windows ML serves as
an abstraction layer
to make it easier for developers
to scale their models
across chipsets and hardware
vendors without having to get
as deep in hardware
specifics or have to deal
with several different SDKs.
With ONNX Runtime integration,
Windows ML also provides a
high degree of flexibility
on what models can
run and where.
Next, performance.
We're partnering with our
silicon partners to make sure
that the latest performance
improvements, innovation,
support for new models and
devices makes it into the stack
through hardware vendor-owned
execution providers.
This way, you get
like-native benefits,
but through one, unified stack.
And third, deployment.
Windows ML provides
a system-wide copy
of runtime dependencies, along
with APIs to help you pull
down the right bits
based on your device.
This way, you don't have
to package those runtime
dependencies with your app,
can reduce your app
size, and don't have
to recompile your app every
time an update takes place.
And with our vendor
certification program,
the bits that are provided from
Windows ML to app developers go
through rigorous,
Windows-specific testing
with every update.
So regardless of how you're
deploying Windows ML,
you're getting the runtime
dependencies that are optimized
for stability,
Windows-maintained,
and will help you have a
smooth update process.
And then, one last thing
to call it on this slide,
Windows ML also provides a
unified tool chain and set
of agent skills, as
we talked about,
such as the Windows ML CLI and
the Foundry Toolkit extension
for VS Code to help developers
prep and optimize their models.
Aditi Narvekar: So that
sentiment analysis workflow,
I wish it was possible to
run that through a website,
so that anyone at the cafe
could access it without having
to download an app or without
having to use the cloud.
Anastasiya Tarnouskaya: Yeah.
Well, the good news is they can.
Not only is Windows ML supported
for your everyday, native
Windows app experiences,
it's also supported for
web apps through WebNN,
which is available in preview
with a few experimental flags
in any Chromium-based browser,
such as Edge or Chrome.
And you can think of WebNN as
the layer that sits on top
of native ML APIs, like
Windows ML on Windows,
providing near-native
access to GPUs, NPUs,
and CPUs through framework APIs.
And that means that even
websites can benefit
from native, Windows ML-based
hardware acceleration
without racking up token costs
or sending sensitive
enterprise data to the cloud.
All right.
So let's see this in action.
And I am once more going to
be using the Surface Laptop
for Business Seventh Edition
laptop with Intel processors.
But this time we're going to
be inferencing the model.
All right.
So here I have VS Code
open with my web app.
And I have the
sentimentanalyzer.js file open,
which is where the bulk of my
inferencing code is going to be.
Some of the key things to call
out here is I'm using the
ONNX Runtime Web APIs,
which are framework
APIs that I can use
for running ONNX
models in the browser.
And under the hood, that's going
to use WebNN, which is going
to be working with
Windows ML to get
that native, Windows ML-based
hardware acceleration.
I'm then going to go ahead
and pass in the models
that I optimized earlier
through the Windows ML CLI.
And then we're going to go ahead
and create our
inference session.
And so to do that, I'm
going to use the WebNN,
create context APIs here to set
up my session, and I'm going
to pass in a device type.
Now initially, this is set to
NPU, but let's actually go ahead
and change it to CPU, because
we're going to want this to work
on all the devices at the
cafe, not just Copilot+ PCs.
So I've gone ahead and updated
that to CPU, and then we'll set
up our inference session by
passing in that context here,
the model data from earlier,
as well as setting the name
of our execution
provider to WebNN.
And then the rest of this file
is just going to take care
of things like model
tokenization, tensorization,
running inference, and then
based off of the model outputs,
classifying my sentiment as
positive, neutral, or negative.
All right.
So let's see this running.
Going to do a hard refresh here.
And as you can see in the
bottom right-hand corner,
we're going to be running this
on the CPU to classify sentiment
for this Decaf Eclipse beverage,
which is a no-caffeine espresso.
So let's see how that's going
to do with the customers
at the Unmetered Token Café.
Okay. So this is now running.
And as you can see, I'm
getting that blip on the CPU
because we're using
the CPU on this device
to classify sentiment
for these reviews
that are coming in.
Nothing needs to
go to the cloud.
I'm getting latency of about 300
milliseconds and about three
and a half reviews getting
classified per second.
So not bad.
And if I take a look
at the slide chart
and the sentiment trend, this
beverage isn't doing the best.
A lot of neutral
sentiment and negative
and positive, roughly equal.
So maybe that was a little
bit of a questionable choice.
All right.
So now let's go ahead and go
back to VS Code, and we're going
to update this to now run on
the NPU, because I also want
to get a sense of what
this is going to look
like for the Copilot+
PCs at the café.
So let's now go back
and refresh this page.
And just to make things more
interesting, we're now going
to classify sentiment for
this Aurora Latte Beverage,
which is a lavender
honey beverage
with a gradient port
from violet to gold.
And as you can see in the
bottom right-hand corner,
this is now going to be
running on my device's NPU.
So let's see how this does.
All right.
Right away you can see blazing
fast performance compared
to what we saw on the CPU.
I'm getting just 30
milliseconds of latency here,
over 11 reviews being classified
per second, so that's more
than times three the reviews --
the rate that we were
seeing for CPUs.
And this beverage is doing
much better as well.
That's great news.
All right.
A lot of positive sentiment.
And negative is very low.
Aditi Narvekar: Yeah, I
think I want to try one
of these Aurora Lattes.
Anastasiya
Tarnouskaya: For sure.
Aditi Narvekar: So this
was a super cool demo,
but is this ready
for production?
Anastasiya Tarnouskaya: Yeah.
Well, Windows ML went to general
availability just last fall,
and already, there are dozens
of partners shipping production
experiences on Windows ML
to general availability.
Those include Adobe,
Canva Affinity,
Speechify, and many others.
And speaking of that,
we actually have a couple
very special guests here.
We have Jordi and Flex, who
are from the VoiceMod team,
who have built a really
compelling experience using
Windows ML that's going
to give you a sense
of just how low-latency
Windows ML
and local AI experiences can be.
And they're going to
be running their demo
on a different device,
on this device,
which is an Asus
Zenbook A16 laptop
with a Qualcomm Snapdragon NPU.
So Jordi and Flex,
welcome, and come on up.
[ Applause ]
Jordi Janer: Hi, everyone.
everyone, I'm Jordi,
Head of Research
and Innovation at VoiceMod.
Flex: Hi, everyone.
My name is Flex.
I'm a Content Creator
and VoiceMod Ambassador.
Jordi Janer: We're a
Windows-first platform
that lets anyone transform
your voice in real time
through voice filters,
soundboards, and creation tools.
Flex: Gamers and streamers
customize everything:
their skins, their
avatars, their setups.
But their voice is still the
one thing left untouched.
That's where VoiceMod comes in.
So anyone can sound
exactly the way they want
to be heard online, whether
in game or in voice chats.
Jordi Janer: And VoiceMod
delivers a sophisticated audio
generation pipeline by combining
digital signal processing
effects and cutting-edge
generative AI
speech-to-speech models.
And to have a truly
immersive experience,
our AI models can operate
at ultra-low latency,
below 45 milliseconds, so that
any voice interaction feels
instantaneous and natural.
And to do that at scale, we've
been building on Windows ML.
And Windows ML has allowed us
to offload heavy AI
inference computation
from the CPU to NPUs and GPUs.
And basically, to us, Windows
ML offers three things: first,
it has allowed to run higher
quality models locally,
so there's no cloud
dependency; second,
it allows to reduce the app
size, thanks to the abstraction
of the execution providers;
and third, it allows us
to deliver four times
faster as we built it once,
and then we could deploy across
our silicon partners: Qualcomm,
Nvidia, AMD, and Intel.
But to better understand
how it works,
I think the best we can
do is to see it live.
So Flex, would you like
to show us the magic?
Flex: Absolutely, Jordi.
We are going to give some spice
to these Fortnite
skins using VoiceMod.
So our first skin here
is called the Ice King,
and I want to give him a
voice that is powerful,
that is scary, that
is commanding.
Maybe something like this.
Maybe a skin like this,
maybe a voice like this.
Or a skin like this?
I don't know.
Let's try, maybe, this voice.
I think this one maybe fits a
little bit better for this guy.
Or actually, let's try this one.
I don't know.
This might not be
the right voice.
What do you think, Jordi?
Jordi Janer: That's cool.
Flex: I agree.
And I feel like everyone
wouldn't mind grabbing a coffee
and sticking around for
the rest of the stream,
but alas, the show must go on.
Jordi Janer: Thanks, Microsoft
Build, and thank you
to the Windows ML team
for making this possible.
[ Applause ]
Anastasiya Tarnouskaya:
Fantastic.
Thank you, Jordi and Flex.
Incredible demo.
And great that
Windows ML was able
to help you scale
your experience
across more Windows devices.
All right.
So finally, let's take a
look at all of what's new
for Windows ML in 2026.
First off, as we talked about,
the Windows ML CLI is available
for you to try out and
preview on GitHub to optimize
and prepare your models.
If you're running generative
AI experiences, for example,
using LLMs or other generative
workflows, you're going
to see some
performance speed up,
so up to times 2.6 throughput
for Gen AI workloads,
depending on which
model you're using.
And if you're using the default
CPU execution provider,
you're going to see some
performance speedups also
with the newest version
of Windows ML that's currently
available in preview.
Next, Windows ML
2.0 has shipped.
That includes ONNX Runtime
improvements and support
for new hardware vendor plugin
execution providers, which,
across the two of those,
is going to mean support
for new models,
fundamentals improvements,
and improved compatibility
between releases.
WebNN is also available for
you to try out and preview,
and that's how you can
bring native, hardware-based
acceleration to your web apps as
well in Chromium-based browsers
through a few
experimental flags.
Then, because of how
Windows ML works,
all apps that are built using
Windows ML also get to benefit
from all of the innovation
that's happening
from across the entire
silicon ecosystem.
So from AMD, Intel, Nvidia,
and Qualcomm, for example,
support for all the newest,
latest, and greatest devices
like Ryzen AI 400 series
processors from AMD,
Intel Core Ultra
Series 3 processors,
the upcoming Nvidia RTX Spark
and DGX Station devices as well,
as well as Qualcomm Snapdragon
X2 Elite processors.
And those aren't the only things
that are new, the new devices,
although those are
definitely very cool.
There are also tons of other
improvements, as you can see
on the slide, ranging across
fundamentals improvements,
performance, tooling
improvements, and so much more.
All right.
Aditi, we've covered a
lot in this session.
What are some of the takeaways
that we should leave
our audience with?
Aditi Narvekar: You're right.
We did cover a ton of content.
So let's bring it all home.
Okay. Through the narrative
of this Unmetered Token Café,
we were able to show
you how easy it is
to get started building
experiences with the AI APIs
and how we've expanded
many of those capabilities
to now run on CPUs and GPUs.
We showed how you can run common
open-source models locally
with Foundry Local.
And now Foundry Local is in GA.
And then we showed how you
can bring your own model
with Windows ML and do complex
optimizations with one CLI tool.
And we are so excited to
see what you all can build
with Microsoft
Foundry on Windows.
So before you all leave,
take out your phones.
We have a ton of resources
to help get you started.
Take a photo of all
of those links there.
We also have other sessions at
Build that might be relevant
that could help you
get started as well.
And then please
scan that QR code.
Provide us feedback on the
session, on our product.
We love to hear from you all.
And then Anastasiya and I will
stick around in the lobby
if you want to come talk
to us, ask us questions.
Thank you all so much.
[ Applause ]